david zobda bonjour bonjour bonjour à
tous vos auditeurs et l'anti nickel qui
nous écoutent
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
nous allons commencer par parler c'est
l'actualité de la bataille parlementaire
qui se joue autour du projet de loi de
finances 2010 9 du gouvernement
d'edouard philippe alors il y a quelques
jours c'était le 20 octobre le parti
progressiste martiniquais saluer
l'efficacité des députés d'un ensemble
pour une martinique nouvelle serge
letchimy et josette manin notamment
parce qu'un amendement de serge letchimy
avait été adopté en commission pour donc
maintenir la défiscalisation concernant
l'acquisition et la construction de
logements sociaux outre mer coûte froid
hier à l'assemblée le gouvernement a
retoqué pour ainsi dire cet amendement a
fait voter le texte initial qui ne
reprend pas donc cette défiscalisation
le gouvernement dit c'est pas la peine
de défiscaliser il ya déjà un crédit
d'impôt il estime que cette
défiscalisation et inefficiente alors au
delà des aspects techniques peut-être un
peu compliqué un pur pour les uns et
pour les autres et parfois même y
compris pour nous journalistes
qu'est ce que ça dit des des rapports
d'abord entre la majorité donc
présidentielle et vous ici et puis plus
globalement le gouvernement qui a pas
l'air de d'avoir les déchets qui chasse
avec vous quand même temps écoutez je
pense que les chaînes gouvernement ne
chasse pas du tout avec les ceux de la
martinique d'une manière générale je
voudrais saluer le travail des
parlementaires il faut être un
formidable il se bat pour notre pays il
faut le saluer nous avons salué en temps
utile
cette petite victoire sur le seul
amendement proposé par l'ensemble de nos
de nos parlementaires activity a pu
passer et puis finalement comme un déni
de démocratie le gouvernement par une
volonté farouche de tout bloquer a dans
la nuit à 5 heures du matin enfin c'est
son droit aussi dans l'est tel saint
lois aussi mais c'est par respect morale
de ce qui a été voté jugé au parlement
prenait reste ans on le convoque ont
sauvé bien donc on voit bien qu'il y a
une volonté farouche du gouvernement
d'appliquer ces décisions dans son
programme de loi de finances et c'est
pour ma part c'est inadmissible
ça nous renvoie au fond de la fère et le
fond de la faire c'est ce projet de loi
finances et notamment le budget de
l'outre-mer qui pour moi est
inacceptable inacceptable dans ce sens
où il comporte treize mesures qui
affaiblissent notre pays et va créer une
situation économique et sociale dégradée
en martinique et c'est inacceptable
c'est inacceptable sur l'abattement
fiscal ou locaux vous le concevez bien
c'est inacceptable sur le logement
social parce que au-delà de ce qu'est ce
qui vous gêne dans l'abattement fiscal
ce qui me gêne c'est une partie des
contribuables de chez nous qui seraient
concernées on le rappelle se passer
d'une partie mills et par les caps a
annoncé par le gouvernement
s'il s'agit de la très largement au delà
et tous les calculs montrent ça c'est
déjà inscrit dans les textes
nous sommes concernés par cet abattement
fiscal et d'autres martiniquais toutes
les classes moyennes sont concernés par
cet abattement là et c'est ça le le
souci mais dans le fond dans le fond
c'est une mesure qui est pour ma part
que je trouve ça complètement inefficace
l'inefficace pour le pays
on perd de l'epargne en perdre la
capacité de soutien de l'économie par
part par la consommation au père
l'attractivité du territoire
c'est les complète magnifique mais la
recette gagné par l'état ils disent
qu'ils vont réinjectés dans l'économie
des outre-mer une première vente et au
levier fiscal qui est à domicilie ici
que nous allons perdre deuxièmement avec
l'abattement avec la suppression de la
tva non perçue récupérable faisant 100
millions que le gouvernement va
reprendre à son compte pour constituer
les 170 millions que le gouvernement
reprendra
il va décider de l'affectation c'est
autant de moyens qui qui ne seront pas
domiciliées en martinique
la décision d'utilisation de ces moyens
là va nous échapper aussi puisque ce
sera un pool
pour le financier qui sera lui en
capacité de décider où sera attribué
soit il pas forcément à la martinique
donc vous voyez il y à il y a dans ce
dans cette loi de finances un aspect
général qui le gêne profondément sur
deux volets le premier volet si que nous
subissons des décisions qui sont prises
par un gouvernement issu des lois de
finances et nous apprenons au détour
d'une loi quel sera notre avenir donc
non de concertation de consultation et
une en dialogue avec voilà et la
deuxième raison la deuxième phase aux
fondamentaux c'est à mon sens à mon sens
c'est qu'il y à la grande et c'est du
gouvernement que nous ne connaissons pas
dit moi je suis désolé je ne veux pas
subir mon avenir je veux le construire
pour l'instant nous subissons l'autre à
venir par des décisions que nous
apprenions détour de loi de finances
c'est inadmissible alors je veux que mon
maître qu'ils ont des choses et nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une posture
réactive
nous réagissons à ce que propose le
gouvernement je pense qu'il faut qu'on
ait bien sa tendance il conçoit dans des
forces de proposition quant voulons-nous
pour la martinique comme collectivement
nous allons peser sur les décisions qui
sont prises par le gouvernement
quelles propositions nous formulons ça
ce sont les élus d'ici à l'inversé dans
le gouvernement tienne un ajustement
d'ajustement saisissant un certain
nombre d'opportunités on parle de la
fiscalité réfléchir ouvrons un véritable
chantier sur la fiscalité locale
on a parlé total ou peut-être pouvant
parler comme vous dites où vont ces
nounous les élus martine inondations
seulement la salle on dément avoir le
chantier de la fiscalité mais ouvrir le
chantier de la fiscalité
ce n'est pas ouvrir aux chantiers pour
des thermiques à sur les moyens qu'on va
attribuer aux collectivité de martinique
c'est aussi ouvrir le chantier du
développement économique et social de
notre pays et rassembler toutes les
forces vives les chefs d'entreprise mais
aussi de l'entreprise de l'économie
classique mais dans l'économie aussi
sociale et solidaire ouvrant le chantier
alors qui doit être consciente yves qui
doit organiser ça alors ça peut être la
cité m ça peut être deux trois élues
présentes mais il faut qu'on soit en
capacité de porter des propositions au
gouvernement pour ne pas subir ce que le
gouvernement veut faire de moi alors le
débat continue au micro qui lui est
fortement des finances donc ça va aller
au sénat
cet amendement peut-être qu'il va
réapparaître en tout cas vous soutenez
toujours serge et de chimie et josette
manin dans cette bataille
assez âpre avec le gouvernement bien
évidemment comme je soutiens aussi les
sénateurs comme je soutiens tous les
parlementaires martiniquais mais domiens
parce que tous les autres y compris ceux
qui sont qui sont revanche ils
comprennent bien l'inutilité
l'inefficacité mais surtout la sélection
attendu la réserve d'olivier servat et
même par exemple 2 certain nombre de
lois qui sont proposées la wii je
soutiens le combat n'est pas terminé
mais nous devons poursuivre quelques
mots parce que ça passe très vite
quelques mots sur le climat qu'il y a à
la collectivité territoriale de
martinique alors on le sait depuis
élections d'alfred marie jeanne à la
présidence du conseil exécutif il ya des
plénières qui sont assez mouvementée
mais en interne aussi là avec cette
grève du personnel qui qui qui perdure
qui perdure bon alors là le dialogue a
l'air d'être amorcé un petit peu avec
notamment le conseiller exécutif francis
carole mais vous david zobda qui est
conseiller à l'assemblée de martinique
qu' il est temps que ça se termine cet
épisode la weed et offre les choses se
terminent et se cale il serait grand
temps ça fait trois ans que l actuelle
majorité est au pouvoir à la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
on va bientôt aborder quatrième budget
cette collectivité il serait temps que
l'on passe à des choses beaucoup plus
offensive beaucoup plus positive pour
l'autre pays
c'est vrai qu'il y a certains nombres de
rbo peut être inhérent à la création
même de la ctm sur l'organisation
générale sur les attributions de
responsabilité sur la gestion du
personnel ya un certain nombre de choses
qu'il faut peut être revoir mais moi je
ne suis pas partisan du cra tous azimuts
vous me connaissez je ne suis pas dans
ces dispositions là et je pense qu'il ya
des choses que l'on peut faire en commun
il faut il faut à mon avis rester sur
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est quoi s'ils
répondent aux préoccupations des
martiniquais et et vous voyez des
quelques aspects positifs dans l'action
de la majorité à l'elysée du pce comme
on dit mais déjà le président du fc sion
un exemple très rapide c'est celui de la
conférence avec les présidents de région
sur les lignes
les locales ça me semble une excellente
je soutiens absolument parce qu'il
repose cette confiance repose sur trois
chantiers
le premier c'est celui de la relation
entre les exécutifs locaux donc la ctn
mais aussi les collectivités et le
gouvernement
on est en plein dedans quel lien quel
rapport ensuite sur les capacités
d'intervention quelles sont elles
quel est le champ de manoeuvre quelle
liberté d'action nous avons sur les
territoires ça pose la question de la de
la poursuite de la décentralisation dont
l'assistant contraire une
recentralisation du pouvoir vers l'état
bon cette question-là épousé le chantier
fiscal est posée la relation caribéenne
est posée ce soient des éléments qui
vont parfaitement sur ce chantier en
particulier mais je suis prêt à y
contribuer parce que ça ça me semble
être le bon sens allez on termine la vie
de soldats parce que dans un an
principalement principe vous devriez
devenir le maire du lamentin puisque
pierre samot a annoncé son retrait en
tout cas de ce mandat là de deux mers
bon alors c'est une transition qui se
fait vraiment tout temps tout en douceur
bon voilà puisque vous êtes premier
adjoint vous êtes déjà depuis longtemps
aux affaires vous êtes de plus en plus
présent concerne les affaires du
lamentin mais néanmoins donc pierre
samoura son bureau il a dix qui
s'occupera et continuera à s'occuper
notamment de tout ce qui concerne la
coopération régionale en particulier
avec cuba on sait que ça lui tient
particulièrement à coeur
mais vous faudra imprimer votre marque
après tant d'années de pierre samot à la
tête de la ville alors vous david zobda
oui écoutez l'interview votre propre que
ça viendra ne vous en faites pas trop tu
m'étonnes ça viendra je suis pas bien ça
vaut bien s'abonner pas david zobda
comme vous le savez bien
mais nous sommes dans un moule commun
qui est celui de bâtir nous avons donc
une philosophie politique nous avons un
programme d'actions et je vais
évidemment poursuivre le projet sur
lequel nous sommes nous avons été élus
dès 2014 pour terminer la mandature
mais entre temps il faut que je sois
aussi la capacité de proposer un nouveau
projet à notre ville du lamentin il est
en construction il sera prêt
les choses se font en douceur parce que
bien ça moi est un homme sage qu'il faut
saluer et qui a la lucidité politique
qui convient et il a il a décidé sans
aucune pression sans que personne ne lui
ai rien demandé d'arrêter et les choses
on se fier de manière tout à fait
réfléchie et pour des vins ils arrêtent
le vin donc je vais inviter l'ensemble
le 20 novembre à ma fille le 20 novembre
c'est ça merci beaucoup merci à vous
bonne journée à tous le monde sur notre
antenne